this is a rather unique RICO conspiracy
where you have a frankly a fraud and
bribery scheme that really nobody had
contemplated before and I think the US
attorney and others have you know said
this is rather unprecedented and I think
everybody agrees with that and John is
unique even in that unique case and that
he didn't pocket the money himself he
didn't use it personally and none of the
students that were attached to these
donations ever went to Stanford so I
don't think if any other defendants that
can say that mm-hmm you're a former
prosecutor I am if you were on the other
side on this one can you imagine you'd
be going back and kicking the trash can
and feeling embarrassed that you guys
literally just got beaten in court as a
federal prosecutor like a defense
attorney you have good days and bad days
I think what happened today
in terms of the Sentencing Guidelines
argument and how that went with the
judge was not how they anticipated
they're probably upset at that but again
this is uh for the big leagues in
federal court so sometimes you run into
a judge who's very well prepared and
doesn't agree with your strategy